BRAVERY OF THE PHILADELPHIA
POLICE DEPARTMENT, LAST NIGHT'S
VIOLENCE HOURS LONG STANDOFF
ENDED WITH NO FATALITIES.
ALL SIX OFFICERS WHO WERE SHOT,
THANK GOD, HAVE BEEN RELEASED
FROM THE HOSPITAL AND JUST AFTER
MIDNIGHT, THE PERPETRATOR
FINALLY SURRENDERED AND HOW DID
SOME OF THE RESIDENTS OF NORTH
PHILLY, HOW DID THEY THINK
THEY'RE POLICE DEPARTMENT?
WE WILL PUT THE MUSIC DOWN.
NOW LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THEY TAUNTED THEM.
THEY SHOVED THEM.
AGAIN, ONLY A FEW.
THEY PELTED THEM WITH OBJECTS.
KYW SAID ONLY 2% OF THE HUNDRED%
THERE, 90 PERCENT DID NOT
INVOLVE THEMSELVES.
THESE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM READY TO TAKE A BULLET.
SIX PHILLY POLICE OFFICERS TOOK
BULLETS YESTERDAY TO MAKE THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD A SAFER PLACE.
THAT'S THE THING'S COPS GET IN
THE MIDDLE OF AN ONGOING CRISIS
LIKE THIS.
A DAY CARE CENTER ACROSS THE
STREET?
THESE OFFICERS SAVING COUNTLESS
LIVES, PUTTING THEMSELVES IN
HARM'S WAY, AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE TAUNTING THEM, PELTING
THEM WITH OBJECTS, TREATING THEM
THIS WAY?
THAT'S BEYOND REPULSIVE.
FRANKLY, JUST LIKE THE ONGOING
FELONY ASSAULT AGAINST POLICE
OFFICERS IN NEW YORK CITY WITH
WATER AND OTHER OBJECTS NOW.
AND TODAY, HERE WE ARE, LESS
THAN 24 HOURS AFTER THE
STANDOFF, POLICE WERE FORCED TO
RESPOND TO YET ANOTHER SHOOTING
IN THE EXACT SAME NEIGHBORHOOD.
FIVE PEOPLE WERE SHOT TODAY.
AND THESE BRAVE PHILLY POLICE
OFFICERS BACK AGAIN AT WORK AND
SOME OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS IN AMERICA.
THEY DESERVE BETTER.
YOU KNOW, I SUSPECT DID WHEN I
WAS ON MY RADIO SHOW YESTERDAY
THAT SOMETHING WASN'T RIGHT.
THE FACT THAT IT WAS ABOUT 940
LAST NIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
PROGRAM.
OUR COVERAGE ON THIS PROGRAM, WE
FOUND OUT ALL THAT TIME, POLICE
OFFICERS WITH PEOPLE THEY HAD
APPREHENDED WERE ON THE SECOND
FOR THE ENTIRE TIME AND THEN
FLEE THEY GOT OUT SAFELY BECAUSE
OF THE GOOD WORK AND DILIGENCE
OF THE COMMISSIONER AND
EVERYBODY ELSE IN ALL
LAW ENFORCEMENT THERE BUT AT THE
VERY SAME TIME THAT THE STANDOFF
IS GOING ON, DEMOCRATS, THE
MEDIUM, THEY WERE EXPLOITING
WHAT WAS AN ONGOING CRISIS FOR
POLITICAL GAIN INSTEAD OF
ACTUALLY COVERING WHAT IS
SERIOUS BREAKING NEWS ON THE
GROUND THAT LIVES AT STAKE HERE
FOR EXAMPLE, FAKE NEWS CNN, LESS
THAN AN HOUR INTO THEIR
BREAKING NEWS COVERAGE,
DEDICATING AN ENTIRE SEGMENT,
PUSHING STRICT GUN CONTROL AND
LESS THAN AN HOUR INTO THE
SHOOTING, POLICE OFFICERS STILL
DUCKING FOR COVER AND RETURNING
FIRE, THERE WAS 2020 HOPEFUL
KAMALA HARRIS IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERA SAYING THIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THESE
INITIAL REPORTS AND I WOULD
STRESS THE WORD, INITIAL.
>> I MEAN, WHEN WILL IT STOP,
RIGHT?
PART OF MY FOCUS ON WHAT WE NEED
TO DO AROUND SMART GUN SAFETY
LAWS IS RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE
TO HAVE MORE ENFORCEMENT AROUND
GUN DEALERS.
90% OF THE GUNS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH CRIME ARE SOLD
BY JUST 5% OF THE GUN DEALERS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
AND SO, AMONG THE MANY PLANS
THAT I HAVE, BOTH IN THE FORM OF
EXECUTIVE ACTION AND ALSO IN THE
FORM OF LEGISLATION, ONE OF THEM
IS TO PUT MORE RESOURCES INTO
THE ATF TO TAKE THE LICENSES OF
GUN WHO VIOLATE THE LAW.
>> Sean: SENATOR HARRIS, IT
WAS LESS THAN AN HOUR, REMEMBER.
THIS WAS THAT ABOUT 526 IN THE
AFTERNOON.
SHE IS SAYING THIS.
AND WE HAVE POLICE OFFICERS AND
PEOPLE APPREHENDED IN THE
BUILDING.
THEY WERE THERE AT 940 AND I.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW ANY OF THE FACTS
ON THE GROUND.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHO THE SHOOTER
WAS, SHE DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING AT
ALL ABOUT THE ONGOING SANTA.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW PEOPLE WERE AT
RISK IN THAT SAME BUILDING WHERE
THERE WAS A LIVE SHOOTER IN
THERE.
ALL THESE PEOPLE RISKING THEIR
LIVES, SERVING AND PROTECTING
THE PEOPLE OF PHILADELPHIA,
KAMALA HARRIS IS IN THE COMFORT
OF THE FAKE NEWS CNN STUDIO
HAWKING A POLITICAL AGENDA ABOUT
SOMETHING SHE KNOWS NOTHING
ABOUT.
BEYOND SICK, UGLY, TWISTED,
SHAMEFUL, AND AS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR, FRANKLY, YOU WOULD
THINK SHE WOULD KNOW BETTER.
AND SEVERAL OTHER TRAINS MANY
DEMOCRATIC HOPEFULS ALSO, YES,
SHAMELESSLY WEIGHING IN DURING
THE ONGOING STANDOFF.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN WAIT FOR IT TO
END NOW.
CHEERS TO JULIE BROWN.
DOESN'T HAVE A SNOWBALL'S CHANCE
IN HELL OF EVER BEING A
PRESIDENT.
BLAMING THE NRA.
WHILE BULLETS ARE STILL FLYING.
CORY BOOKER, ON ROSWELL RACHEL
MADDOW'S CONSPIRACY TV HOUR,
CALLING FOR FEDERAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
IT STILL WASN'T RESOLVED.
PRETTY DISGUSTING.
SADLY, NOT SHOCKING, NOT
SURPRISING.
ALL TOO PREDICTABLE.
AND WE CAN'T FORGET, LAST WEEK,
IT WAS ELIZABETH WARREN AND
KAMALA HARRIS.
THEY WERE LITERALLY ADVANCING
THOSE OLD LIES, 5-YEAR-OLD LIES
AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT
HAVE BEEN DEBUNKED ABOUT MICHAEL
BROWN.
LIES DEBUNKED BY ONE EYEWITNESS
AFTER ANOTHER THAT SAW THE
INCIDENT.
EVEN OBAMA'S JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DIDN'T AGREE WITH THE ANALYSIS
OF KAMALA HARRIS AND
ELIZABETH WARREN.
THERE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT POINTED
OUT ALL THE EYEWITNESS TESTIMONY
ON THE GROUND.
AND EVEN NOW, AFTER ANOTHER
SHOOTING, DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIAN
AMOUNT, THEY ARE ALMOST TO GET
HE HAD A CHANCE ONCE AGAIN TO
POLITICIZE A STRATEGY.
VERY PREDICTABLE, VERY SAD.
BUT THINK ABOUT THIS, EVERY
WEEKEND THERE ARE DOZENS OF
SHOOTINGS AND SEVERAL OF
AMERICA'S BIGGEST CITIES.
LET'S LOOK AT THE CITY OF
CHICAGO.
TWO WEEKENDS, LAST TWO WEEKENDS
ALONE, NEARLY 100 PEOPLE WERE
SHOT.
NEARLY 100 PEOPLE.
THESE VIOLENT CITIES HAVE BEEN
RUN FOR DECADES BY LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS.
THESE STUDIES ALL HAVE ONE THING
IN COMMON.
VERY STRICT GUN LAWS.
SO GUESS WHAT?
WE DON'T HEAR A PEEP FROM
DEMOCRATS.
THE ONES THAT ARE GETTING ALL
UPSET, RAISING MONEY OFF THE
EVENTS IN EL PASO AND THE EVENTS
IN DAYTON,
OUT OF THEM ABOUT CHICAGO.
IT DOESN'T FIT THEIR POLITICAL
AGENDA.
ULTIMATELY, THE LEFT'S HYSTERIA
OVER GUN CONTROL HAS VERY LITTLE
TO DO WITH THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
BEING SHOT.
IN PENNSYLVANIA FOR EXAMPLE,
VIOLENT FELONS, THEY ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO PURCHASE GUNS.
IT'S ILLEGAL.
LAST NIGHT SHOOTER WAS A
CONVICTED VIOLENT FELON WITH AT
LEAST A DOZEN ARRESTS, INCLUDING
THE ILLEGAL POSSESSION OF A FIRE
ARMS AND AGGRAVATED ASSAULT AND
YET, HE WAS IN POSSESSION OF
MULTIPLE GUNS.
NO NEW LAW WAS GOING TO STOP
HIM.
HE HAD BELONGED IN JAIL AND
MEANWHILE, THE SHOOTERS IN
EL PASO, DAYTON, THEY ARE NO
FELONIES ON THEIR RECORDS, THERE
IS NO BACKGROUND CHECK THAT
WOULD LIKELY HAVE EVER STOPPED
THEM FROM PURCHASING ANY WEAPON.
SO THIS IS ALL FEEL GOOD IS ON
IN THE NAME OF THE STRICTER AND
STRICTER GUN CONTROL.
INNOCENT PEOPLE WHO ARE
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS THAT HAVE
THE RIGHT TO DEFEND THEIR HOMES
AND FAMILIES.
MURDER IS ILLEGAL IN EVERY STATE
OF THIS COUNTRY CREATE SHOOTING
PEOPLE IS ILLEGAL.
A SECT IN SELF-DEFENSE.
CRIMINALS DON'T SEEM TO CARE.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO FOLLOW THE
LAW OF THE VERY NATURE OF WHAT
THEY DO LIKE THE REST OF US AND
IN A COUNTRY WITH OPEN BORDERS,
GUNS WILL ALWAYS BE AVAILABLE.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD HELP CONTROL
THE BORDERS.
BUT IF DEMOCRATS AND WEAK
REPUBLICANS NOW GET THEIR WAY,
THOSE OF US WHO FOLLOW THE LAW
ARE RESPONSIBLE, WE WOULD BE
LEFT TOTALLY ON ARMED AND
DEFENSIVE'S.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE HAD A 2020
HOPEFUL COMRADE DeFAZIO.
THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY.
HE WOULDN'T ANSWER ANY QUESTION
I ASKED AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
HE HAD HIS ARMED SECURITY GUARDS
WITH HIM.
I ASKED WHETHER PEOPLE IN THE
CITY OF NEW YORK HAVE THE RIGHT
TO HAVE A GUN IN THEIR HOUSE IF
GOD FORBID SOMETHING HAPPENS.
HE KEPT SAYING, THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO BE SAY.
I SET IT AND ASK IT I PAY DO
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO A GUN?
IT'S BECAUSE I HAVE A RIGHT TO
BE SAVED.
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO BE SAFE.
THAT MEANS NO.